ok donc ma présentation s'intitule libre
arbitre et neurosciences
je vais penser en bonne philosophe par
vous définir des termes comme si
j'allais faire une dissertation ce ne
sera pas le cas mais assurez vous donc
le libre arbitre
c'est la capacité à choisir librement la
capacité qu'on a de déterminer notre
propre volonté et c'est une notion qui a
été initiée on va dire par
saint-augustin donc au ivème siècle
après jésus-christ est à l'origine
c'était pour justifier l'existence du
mal c'est à dire que pour saint-augustin
dieu ne peut vouloir le mal or le mal
existe c'est un fait
donc c'est l'homme qui doit être
responsable du mal et donc l'homme doit
être libre de ses actions de ses choix
il se trouve qu'aujourd'hui les avancées
des neurosciences donc les neurosciences
ce sont toutes ces science qui étudie le
cerveau le système nerveux et qui
regroupe à la fois l'anatomie la
physiologie mais aussi la psychologie
l'informatique les mathématiques dans
toutes ces différentes disciplines se
sont regroupés dans les années 60 70 et
ont mis en commun leur donner leur
méthodologie pour étudier le cerveau il
se trouve que c'est neurosciences nous
disent aujourd'hui que nous n'avons pas
les bras
alors je voudrais en quelques minutes
vous exposez 6,6 et ces données sont
vraiment alarmant fait qu'effectivement
nous n'avons aucune capacité à choisir
librement ou si il reste un petit peu
d'espoir et que peut-être nous avons
cette capacité et dans quelle mesure
nous avons cette capacité
vous pouvez me répondre oui mais c'est
pas nouveau les sciences depuis déjà le
xviiie siècle nous disent que dans
l'univers tout était terminé et que à
partir du moment où je sais
ce qui se passe à un instant t je peux
prédire ce qui va se passer demain je
peux inférées ce qui s'est passé dans le
passé s'était notamment l'idée de la
place donc au début du 19e siècle qui
formulent cette idée en disant qu' une
intelligence suprême une intelligence
omnisciente qui pour un instant donné
connaîtrait toutes les forces de la
nature
toutes les forces dont la nature est
animée et la situation respective des
êtres qui la composent
si d'ailleurs cette intelligence était
assez vaste pour soumettre toutes ces
données à l'analyse embrasse très dans
la même formule
le mouvement des plus grands corps de
l'univers et ceux du plus légères at
home rien ne serait incertain pour elle
et l'avenir comme le passé serait
présent à ses yeux donc ça c'est l'idée
qui a lancé la physique classique qui
est encore présente aujourd'hui puisque
les scientifiques essayent de dégager
des régularités des lois de
fonctionnement de la nature
or l'homme est situé dans la nature
est-ce que l'homme répond également à
ces régularités à ses lois ou est ce que
on se situe en dehors de cet univers
donc si on adopte une position
matérialiste qui est la plus commune
aujourd'hui l'homme est situé dans la
nature et devrait elle son comportement
ses choix ses actions devraient
s'expliquer en termes déterministe mais
les neurosciences ajoute quand même
quelques données à cette position
fondamentale puisque des expériences
faites par benjamin liban dans les
années 80
là on va peut-être passer voilà des
expériences effectuées par benjamin
nivet
les années 80 ont montré que un
potentiel électrique s'activent dans
notre cerveau quelques centaines de
millisecondes avant qu'on prenne
conscience de notre décision d'agir
alors comment il a montré ça et il a
demandé à des participants qui étaient
équipées avec un électroencéphalogramme
donc autour du crâne un électromyogramme
qui enregistrait l'activité musculaire
au niveau du de la main donc déjà ça
aide à se sentir très libre ça le il
leur a demandé de fixer ce cadran et de
laisser advenir une envie spontanée de
lever l'index tout simplement
donc pour lui c'était le 20 10 ans ce
qui représente par excellence de notre
libre arbitre
bon ça peut se discuter mais donc
pendant que le sujet fixait ce cadran et
laisser advenir cette envie de fléchir
l'eulex sens déterminé à l'avancé un
moment auquel il allait fléchir index
mais néanmoins en rapportant l'endroit
où le point lumineux était au tour du
cadran au moment où il prenait cette
décision
donc tout ça c'était un peu compliqué
mais en tout cas ils ont demandé donc au
sujet de rapporter le moment et prennent
leurs décisions et en même temps ils
enregistraient leur activité cérébrale
et ils ont montrés benjamin nivet et son
équipe que un potentiel électrique
s'activent dans le cerveau 210 500
millisecondes avant l'action mais 300
millisecondes avant que le sujet décide
consciemment de lever l'intox ce qui
semble montrer que notre cerveau d'une
certaine façon initie déclenche l'action
avant même que nous ayons conscience de
vouloir fléchir nymex donc effectivement
c'est ça remet en question en tout cas
l'idée qui est présente dans la notion
de libre arbitre
selon laquelle nous sommes la source
ultime de nos actes de nos choix n'y a
pas de source ultime puisque tout est
prédéterminé par
des événements inconscient cérébraux qui
sont complètement hors de notre
conscience
peut-être on peut passer à une machine
ans
oui où celle-ci flashy donc ça c'était
simplement le déroulé temporel donc là
vous avez le potentiel électrique dans
le cerveau inconscient donc là la
décision consciente et ici l'acte moteur
donc c'est dans cet ordre là que ça se
sache se déroule alors j'ai essayé moi
dans mon livre qui s'intitule un nouveau
libre arbitre de d'inclure ces données
de les prendre en compte et de voir si
ces expériences pouvait néanmoins laissé
la place à une certaine capacité de
l'hydre à pitre et la redéfinition que
je propose s'articule en deux parties
d'une part disons que il a été montré
que certains processus inconscients
peuvent néanmoins faire l'objet d'une
prise de conscience
je vais repartir au départ les des
expériences très célèbre en psychologie
qui ont montré que quand on effectue une
un choix une décision la plupart du
temps on n'a pas conscience des causes
qui détermine notre choix par exemple
une équipe suédoise a montré que quand
on demande à un participant de choisir
entre deux visages lequel ils préfèrent
et que par un tour de magie on vers
présente la photo qu'il n'a pas choisie
mais qu'on lui demande pourquoi tu as
choisi cette photo c'est prêt mais ce
cas mais la personne effectivement 20
rationaliser ce choix qu'elle m'a pas
fait qu'elle va dire mais la personne
n'avait un plus joli sourire etc etc
cependant ce protocole a été reproduit
avec une méthode d'entretien qui amène
le participant à rediriger son attention
sur les processus cognitifs qui l'ont
mené à effectuer ce choix c'est à dire
qu'en fait
quand on demande pourquoi on a choisi ce
visage la plupart du temps on va
automatiquement aléas des raisons les
raisons les plus probables
on va pas prendre le temps de se
remettre la position du moment où on a
choisi cette image et quelques caisses
qui a guidé notre choix exactement
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on a vu qu est
ce qu on a senti que ce qu'on a
emotionnellement ressenti par rapport à
deux visages par exemple et en
l'occurrence cette technique d'entretien
permet d'inverser les données de
l'équipe suédoise
c'est à dire que quand les participants
sont guidés de cette façon ils détectent
la manipulation dans 80% des cas
alors que là qu'ils étaient manipulés et
ne s'en rendait pas compte et
rationalisent est un choix qui n'avait
pas fait dans 80% des cas
donc tout ça pour dire que il est
possible de déteindre notre conscience
donc des processus inconscients peuvent
devenir conscient moyennant une
redirection de l'attention et c'est une
partie de la définition que je veux
amener aujourd'hui c'est à dire que le
libre arbitre
ce ne serait pas une capacité d'être la
source ultime de nos actes il ya bien
sûr des tas de choses qui nous
déterminent mais on peut dans une
certaine mesure développer cette
capacité donc c'est un apprentissage
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
présupposer d'office moyennant donc une
entraînement de nos capacités
attentionnelles et la deuxième partie de
ma re définition c'est que n'ont
peut-être pas c'est l'image suivante il
ya également des expériences en
neurosciences qui ont été menées sur les
fesses troupe donc les fesses troupes
sont en effet très connu en psychologie
c'est l'effet qui fait que ici si je
vous demande la couleur de lancre de ce
mot c'est plus facile et plus rapide
pour vous de répondre que si je vous
demande la couleur de lancre de ce mot
là normalement être plus si vous êtes
anglophone puisque là en l'occurrence
les mouches sont en anglais
tout simplement parce que en eau la
couleur de landes correspond à la
signification du mot à leur combat la
couleur de l'anc ne correspond pas à la
signification de cet effet c'est un
effet très automatique c'est quelque
chose qu'on ne peut pas contrôler mais
un chercheur à l'université mcgill de
montréal s'appelle amer rase a montré
que en réalité cet effet pouvaient être
des automates y est donc un effet très
automatiques tels que celui ci peut être
d automatiser avec une suggestion
hypnotique d'interpréter cette chaîne de
lettres comme une chaîne sans
signification
donc si on met un participant à une
étude sous hypnose qu'on lui dit que
cette chaîne de lettres n'a aucune
signification
l'effet automatique va être content et
automatisée est réduit ça veut dire que
même des processus inconscients très
automatisé peuvent être modifiées et ça
montre que des donc des comportements
que nous avons quotidien qui sont très
automatique et parfois c'est très utile
quand on conduit une voiture c'est mieux
de ne pas se poser des questions sans
arrêt sur ce qu'il faut faire au niveau
des pédales au niveau de la boîte de
vitesses etc
au bout d'un moment ça devient très
automatique est tant mieux d'autres
comportements parfois on aimerait bien
s'en passer par exemple fumer 30
cigarettes par jour ou avalé une boîte
de gâteaux
quand on en a envie parce qu'on peut pas
se retenir par exemple toutes sortes de
compulsion de ce genre c'est sa montre
en fait que ces comportements qui ont
été automatisés avec le temps peuvent
être d automatiser et nous faire
retrouver une feinte de flexibilité et
élargir le
le répertoire d'actions disponibles
voilà donc en gros l'idée c'est que les
neurosciences nous ont montré au départ
que le livradais pouvait être compromis
parce que effectivement on a des
précurseurs inconsciente nos décisions
sur lesquelles on n'a pas forcément le
contrôle ça me semble être déterminé par
ces précurseurs inconscient mais à la
clé se trouverait dans les neurosciences
elle même que la tension constitue une
capacité essentielle qui modulent ce qui
va entrer dans le champ de la conscience
ou non et donc je voudrais simplement
voilà montré que le libre arbitre existe
encore mais qu'il est peut être un peu
plus difficile d'accès que ça nécessite
un entraînement de nos capacités
attentionnelles sur le long terme et je
vous remercie de votre attention